what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
today i have a quick video for you in
regards to a bunch of upcoming trailers
not just the spider-man far from home
one which of course we are going to talk
about but hawkeye miss marvel the
eternals and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness side note tonight
i will be attending the red carpet world
premiere of shang qi and the legend of
the 10 rings in la with my buddies the
real rejects greg and john and we are
allowed to post our reaction immediately
after watching the movie so be sure to
stay tuned to see what we thought about
shanghai and the legend of the tin rings
and be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so obviously
we have to start with spider-man far
from home and some of you may have heard
this but for those of you who didn't
things are actually getting pretty
interesting and looking pretty good for
a spider-man trailer relatively soon
according to a few different sources
right now the trailer for spider-man no
way home right now is being dubbed in
india this is great news on a couple
different levels one it means that the
trailer is actually done and this is
something that we actually were
wondering about because they are
currently still doing reshoots for
spider-man no way home and we didn't
really know if these reshoots had to be
done before they actually completed the
trailer but they wouldn't have begun to
dub it in india if it wasn't already
done because they need the whole thing
obviously and for those of you who are
unaware of what dubbing it means it
means the voice actors are recording
their parts in hindi and this means that
it's most likely going to be dubbed in
other languages pretty soon as well so
again good news that means it's
completed and the other good news is of
course this puts us closer to actually
getting the release of the trailer these
past couple of weeks it's kind of been
unknown when to expect it there had been
reports and rumors that it was going to
come out before what if that obviously
wasn't true and over the past week or so
we were all pretty much concerned that
they weren't released in the trailer
because they might be thinking about
delaying the release date of spider-man
knowing home just like they recently did
with venom let there be carnage now the
good news is venom 2 was only delayed a
few weeks not a month or a few months
only a few weeks so if they truly were
thinking about pushing back the release
date of no way home they're probably
only going to push it back a little
which would only delay the trailer just
a little bit as well but as of right now
we are pretty much almost exactly four
months away from the actual movie's
release and four months out is usually
when they released the teaser trailer
sony did this for venom let there be
carnage then two months later they
followed it up with the official
full-length trailer obviously spider-man
no way home is a little bit different
but let's hope they stick to pretty much
the same pattern now cinemacon is coming
up in a week and sony is set up to start
off the very first day and they are
supposed to show exclusive footage of
their upcoming projects which obviously
spiderman no way home is and since the
fact that the trailer is being dubbed
means that it's complete that means that
they have a full trailer ready to show
at cinemacon so it could be very
possible that they are going to show the
trailer a week from today but remember
they're not going to release the trailer
to the public they're just going to show
it to people inside of cinemacon sadly
this is what they've always done however
that's not going to stop people from
going on the internet and telling us
what they saw so at the very least we
should have at least a description for
the spider-man no way home teaser
trailer next monday if they do indeed
show the trailer or simply any footage
at all and hopefully we get more on that
soon and if i hear anything of course
i'll let you know now some good news is
that there are a bunch of rumors going
around right now that we should be
getting the hawkeye trailer this month
or at the latest at the emmys now this
makes perfect sense because right now
the release date for hawkeye is supposed
to be november 24th of this year that
means we're only about three months away
from it which means we're about due for
a trailer for it what if has already
begun chongqi is about to start so the
promotion for hawkeye should be able to
pick up pretty soon here so keep an eye
out for that hawkeye trailer we're also
most likely to get a new eternals
trailer relatively soon with the release
of shang chi rumors have it right now
that before shang chi plays in the movie
theaters during the previews there will
be an eternals trailer attached to it in
fact there's actually been word that
some theaters have already begun to play
some new eternals footage before certain
movies but it's believed that a full new
trailer showing new footage is going to
be before shanghai now the trailer for
miss marvel is also rumored to be coming
either during the emmys or disney plus
day if it comes in 2021 right now it's
kind of up in the air on whether or not
it is going to release in 2021 but an
executive at disney did say that it was
a 2021 feature but we'll have to see
about that however if it is a 2021
feature obviously we're going to get the
trailer relatively soon the emmys coming
up on september 19th would be a perfect
opportunity for marvel to release a
couple of trailers for their new disney
plus shows hawkeye and miss marvel so
keep an eye out for that as well and
last but not least a lot of people have
been asking me about doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness when we can
expect to see a trailer if we can expect
to see that trailer in 2021 and i say
yes i do think it's very possible to get
a trailer for multiverse of madness
perhaps with spiderman no way home the
two movies are very directly connected
it comes out in december and i do really
think that the post-credits scene for
spider-man no way home is going to be
about doctor strange i mean spider-man
know at home already as it is is going
to feature doctor strange as a main
character is going to play a very
important part so it just makes sense
that the post-credits scene would have
something to do with his movie and this
is why i believe that the trailer could
be attached to it or sometime quickly
after now the teaser is going to have to
be pretty vague especially if you have
to watch the events of spider-man away
home to really realize what's happening
but since multiverse of madness comes
out on march 25th of 2022 three months
after spider-man no way home they can't
wait until everybody watches it to drop
the first trailer they have to drop it
sooner than that so it's most likely
coming in 2021 if not at the latest very
early 2022. and those are the trailers
that we are all keeping our eyes out for
right now obviously spider-man no way
home being the biggest one and all
exciting nonetheless and speaking of
exciting news it has been reported that
jonathan magers has begun filming his
kang the conqueror scenes for ant-man 3
ant-man and the wasp quantomania and i
think everybody knows what this means we
are about to get some pretty cool leaks
typically when everything starts filming
things get out they've done a pretty
decent job on spiderman no way home in
fact i think only one photo has leaked
that has doctor strange in it the other
marvel has released themselves and of
course we've seen absolutely no photos
of anybody from any type of other
multiverse but i think they're taking
extra precautions on this film because
typically we do get a good amount of
leaks and dive for one i'm really really
excited to see what this new kang
because this is not the same king from
loki as he mentioned his other variants
are a lot more evil than him so this
king is going to be a lot different in
fact he who remains wasn't kang at all
he was peaceful he was actually trying
to help despite his unusual methods but
kang is only going to want to conquer
and he is going to be much worse and i'm
hoping that he gets his traditional
purple and green costume so that's what
i'm on the lookout for right now some
leaked photos of king the conqueror and
ant-man and the wasp quantomania and it
sure does seem like since king is the
master of time travel and this is
ant-man and the wasp quantum mania king
at least harnessed some of the powers of
the quantum realm for time travel kang
does use specific devices that allow him
to time travel in the comics but who
knows in the mcu the quantum realm is
probably the key to everything so i'll
be excited to see some leaked photos of
either a time traveling chair or throne
or a ship of some sort and i really
think that ant-man 3 is going to be a
pretty big movie and ant-man is about to
become a very very prominent avenger so
let me know what you think about all
this news in the comments down below and
besides spider-man no way home because i
know everybody's most excited for that
trailer what trailer are you most
excited for don't forget to like the
video and subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof